with proven rates dropping around the
country many businesses are bringing
their employees back to the office and
look i've enjoyed working from home
there's no irritating commute no boss
breathing down your neck no arbitrary
time constraints honestly it's been nice
but with that said there's also
something missing and i think deep down
everyone who has been working from home
probably feels it too so i made this
video to show you what i
mean you've been baxed and boosted and
the rates are coming down
[Music]
you got word from your boss
that they want you back in town
you are headed back to the office
and it feels just a little sad
but then something reminds you
that it won't be
so
bad
[Music]
it's been two years since you talked
you used to spend all your weekdays
together monday friday it never was
better but then covet hit and we all
went away
you're ghosted the colleagues you used
to talk to each day
[Music]
work friends using them enter and call
word friend using them blake's a ball
[Music]
[Applause]
hey brian what's up amber how you been
can't complain how are the kids i don't
have kids how's the wife never been
married right oh and my name isn't brian
it's jeff oh sorry
great to see you again jeff great to be
back work friends
not like you would type or even that
close you've only seen them dressed in
business casual clothes 40 hours a week
you had to co-exist and you told them
things you don't even tell your
therapist
did i ever tell you guys about the time
i tried dmt no when when was that i was
at this massive sweaty orgy in college
and i've never spoken about it to a soul
since wow okay uh what made you bring it
up now i don't know
i guess i was just trying to impress my
work friends you've seen them on zoom
work friends and now you're in the same
room
work friends time to get back in touch
work friends you've missed them all so
hey
can you guys shut the hell up i want a
conference call
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you